Profª. Tamar Gendler: Portanto,
o nosso tema de hoje é
a questão geral de que tipo de
persuasão não-racional
é legítima para um governo se envolver
se estamos dispostos a aceitar o
argumento do contrato social
que estivemos considerando nas
últimas semanas do curso.
Vocês se lembram que,
a partir do modelo de justiça
oferecido em A República de Platão,
e seguindo com o modelo do estado
de natureza de Hobbes,
cada um dos nossos autores têm sugerido
que é do nosso interesse próprio,
numa forma de endossarmos reflexivamente
as estruturas governamentais,
renunciar algumas de nossas liberdades
a fim de garantir um certo
tipo de estabilidade.
Mas os tipos de restrições
consideradas nas discussões anteriores
se preocupavam com leis explícitas.
A preocupação delas era com
as formas que pactuamos
com os regulamentos que
reconhecemos como superiores a
nós
e que apoiamos porque vemos
razão para isso.
O argumento que Hobbes apela para a
noção do Dilema do Prisioneiro,
um paradoxo da racionalidade.
É um problema que surge quando
os interesses próprios
entram em conflito de forma particular
e interagem com os incentivos
de forma particular.
O que vimos no final da última aula e
o que veremos na aula de hoje
são as maneiras pelas quais os
seres humanos são complexos.
Eles têm, como sabemos a partir
das nossas aulas iniciais,
não só a razão, mas
também partes da sua alma
afetadas por outras coisas
além da razão.
E isso também acaba tendo
implicações para que as estruturas
políticas seja racionais
para ter o nosso apoio.
Na aula de hoje, veremos, por um lado,
o argumento de Platão que
no estado ideal
deveria existir uma censura
bastante radical
do tipo de representações
ficcionais autorizadas;
e o argumento de Cass Sunstein que
um dos deveres do governo
é estabelecer normas que afetam
as pessoas implicitamente
em como elas estruturam o
comportamento delas.
Portanto, numa aula sobre este tema,
parece apropriado começar com
algumas histórias.
Histórias verdadeiras sobre
histórias falsas e os seus efeitos.
Portanto, em 1992, bem na
época que muitos de vocês
estavam nascendo, também nascia
na televisão uma jovem
personagem midiática
chamada Murphy Brown.
Mas isso, em si, não é notícia.
O que tem valor é que, na época,
Murphy Brown era solteira.
Na verdade, ela não tinha um
parceiro estável.
E o então vice-presidente dos
Estados Unidos, Dan Quayle,
fez um célebre discurso em São
Francisco em 1992 que dizia:
"O casamento é uma questão moral
que exige consenso e o uso
de sanção social.
Não ajuda em nada quando uma
televisão em horário nobre
tem Murphy Brown, uma personagem
que supostamente simboliza
a mulher inteligente, profissional
e bem-sucedida de hoje,
burlando da importância de um pai
ao ter um filho sozinha
e chamando isso de apenas
uma opção de vida."
Agora, de fato, Dan Quayle
deturpou um pouco
o que acontecia no seriado.
Embora Murphy Brown não
tivesse um parceiro estável
e criasse um filho sem o apoio de
uma 2ª figura adulta,
isso não poderia ser chamado de
apenas uma opção de vida.
Mas ele estava correto em que o
seriado não retratava
os custos para Murphy Brown ao ter
de reconfigurar a sua vida
de tal modo que ela se
tornaria uma "cuidadora".
O que é interessante é que se
trata de uma pessoa real,
Dan Quayle, o vice-presidente
real do país real,
os Estados Unidos da
América, pondo em causa
o nascimento imaginário de uma
criança que não era, de fato,
o filho da atriz que
interpretou Murphy Brown...
e ele viu isso corroendo os valores
considerados importantes.
Além disso, este debate
bombardeou os noticiários
de uma forma incrível.
Foi capa da Time.
Foi capa do New York Post:
"Dan destroça Murphy Brown."
O New York Daily News disse:
"Quayle para Murphy Brown:
Sua vagabunda!"
O The New York Times publicou um
artigo alguns meses depois,
quando, num ato de enorme ironia
pós-moderna, Murphy Brown,
a personagem da TV,
respondeu a Dan Quayle,
o vice-presidente real.
E o The New York Times oferecia um texto
que começava assim:
"Quase todo mundo que assiste à
televisão está ciente de que,
esta noite, Murphy Brown responde ao
vice-presidente Dan Quayle,
que carregou os valores da família
na linha de frente da campanha
presidencial de 1992
criticando a personagem
principal da série
por ter um filho fora do casamento."
Esta é a história número 1.
Aqui está a história número 2.
Mais recentemente, em 2002, o
seriado 24 Horas representou
o presidente dos EUA como um homem
de ascendência africana.
Em 2007, esse mesmo programa retratou
o presidente dos EUA como uma mulher.
Em 2008, como vocês sabem, os 2
principais candidatos
para a nomeação presidencial
do Partido Democrata
eram um homem de ascendência
africana e uma mulher.
E era comum ver os comentaristas
que analisam as eleições
dizendo coisas como as deste
blog da Newsweek.
O que reforça que a disponibilidade
na representação ficcional
de um personagem que atuou como
presidente e era de ascendência
africana ou que atuou como
presidente e era uma mulher
teve algum papel em permitir que os
cidadãos reais no mundo real
– e não pessoas
imaginárias da TV –
tivessem um espaço conceitual
disponível para a possibilidade
de eleger um presidente desse tipo.
Dan Quayle e os analistas
sobre o 24 Horas foram,
como se sabe a partir da
nossa leitura para hoje,
ecoando o nosso amigo Platão.
Dan Quayle essencialmente quis dizer:
"Se quisermos que os
guardiões da nossa cidade..."
– que são os cidadãos que estão
em posição para governar
e escolher a liderança – "...
considerem o cúmulo da vergonha
discutir levianamente"
(leia-se: vergonha ter um
filho fora do casamento)
"deve-se também evitar
contar que os deuses..."
– nas palavras de
Platão; nas de Quayle:
as personagens atraentes da TV –
"... fazem guerra entre si
e que armam ciladas recíprocas".
Ou seja, o exercício da atividade
a que queremos proibir.
Portanto, quando Platão diz: "Se
quisermos que os guardiões
da nossa cidade considerem o cúmulo da
vergonha discutir levianamente,
deve-se também evitar
contar que os deuses
fazem guerra entre si e que
armam ciladas recíprocas",
ele argumentando algo que Dan
Quayle usou 2.000 anos depois.
E na medida em que os
analistas da Newsweek
discutem sobre a eleição
presidencial de 2008,
satisfeitos ao ver uma abertura do
leque de candidatos que estavam
sendo levados a sério como
potenciais líderes desta nação,
eles também foram ecoando Platão,
que logo após a última
citação, completa:
"Se quisermos convencê-los de que
jamais a discórdia reinou
entre os cidadãos e que
tal coisa é ímpia,
devemos fazer com que os adultos lhes
digam isto desde a infância".
Ou seja, histórias,
representações ficcionais,
experiências imaginárias que se
tornam parte da conversa cultural,
podendo fornecer modelos
que são tanto problemáticos
quanto inspiradores.
Agora, o quebra-cabeça
proposto, se pensarmos
nos termos da
racionalidade, é o
seguinte:
Como algo que sabemos ser fictício
pode afetar os nossos
comportamentos e atitudes reais?
No é que as pessoas que
assistiam ao 24 Horas
realmente pensassem David Palmer
era o presidente dos EUA.
Não é que as pessoas que
assistiam ao Murphy Brown
realmente pensassem que a figura
interpretada por Candice Bergen
tinha um filho.
As pessoas estavam
profundamente conscientes
de que eram representações ficcionais.
E até mesmo as crianças
são notavelmente boas
em separar a pretensão da realidade.
Se você fizer um chá imaginário
com uma criança pequena,
onde você despeja o chá
imaginário numas xícaras
desde um bule vazio, as crianças
estão perfeitamente prontas
para concordar que as xícaras estão
cheias no contexto da pretensão.
Mas nenhuma criança que esteja
com sede realmente pensa
que vai encontrar chá numa
dessas xícaras.
Se você brincar com uma criança
de fazer bolinhos de massa de
modelar, elas ficam chocadas
e contrariadas se você
realmente tentar morder um.
E os adultos também têm a
capacidade de determinar
o que é imaginário e o que é real.
Bem, temos a capacidade por
uma parte da alma.
A resposta para o quebra-cabeça que
dá origem às preocupações
articuladas por Platão, Dan
Quayle e pelos blogueiros,
é que a ficção causa
problemas ao afetar
as partes não-racionais
da alma de formas
que não estão facilmente sujeitas à
regulação ou ao controle racional.
Esta estrutura já é familiar para nós
pelas nossas discussões gerais
sobre as partes da alma.
Sabemos que
se eu ficar numa superfície de
vidro acima do Grand Canyon
e olhar para baixo, onde passa o
impetuoso rio Colorado,
embora a minha racionalidade me
diga que estou segura,
as peças não-racionais da
minha alma são afetadas
por este estímulo visual de tal
forma que me fazem tremer.
E mesmo que eu tente convencer vocês
de que o que parece ser uma caixa
de areia para gatos é,
na verdade, um bolo de chocolate
coberto com bombons e coco...
embora a parte racional da sua
alma acredite em mim,
é bastante difícil regular
as outras partes.
Tal como na série de
quebra-cabeças que analisamos
no contexto da tradição das
heurísticas e vieses.
Se eu apresentar uma opção
onde você está tentando
obter 1 bola vermelha
num recipiente que contém 9
bolas brancas e 1 vermelha
ou num recipiente com 92 bolas
brancas e 8 vermelhas,
embora a parte racional da sua alma
seja profundamente consciente
de que tem 10% de chance aqui e
8% ali, é o caso de,
se eu colocar você sob a carga
cognitiva de tal modo
que a parte racional não esteja em
posição de fazer a decisão,
você será atraído para o
recipiente com mais bolas
em vez do que apresenta uma
proporção maior.
A razão não é suficiente
para regular as partes
não-racionais da alma.
E, outra vez, no contexto da nossa
discussão sobre tentação,
sobre fraqueza da vontade.
Aqui está Ulisses,
amarrado ao mastro...
racionalmente empenhado em
superar as sereias,
mas incapaz de fazê-lo sem
bloquear os ouvidos
para se prevenir da tentação dos
cantos ou de se amarrar ao mastro
de tal forma que ele seja
incapaz de agir.
Platão diz isso quando ele identifica
o que há de tão problemático nas
representações ficcionais.Ele diz:
O poeta imitativo está "relacionado com
o elemento inferior da alma".
Lembrem-se que Platão tem a hierarquia:
razão, espírito, apetite.
Ele "desperta, alimenta e
fortalece o elemento mau da alma
e arruína o elemento racional.
[...] introduz um mau governo na
alma de cada indivíduo,
lisonjeando o que nela há
de irracional".
Portanto, o fato de saber, com a
parte razão da nossa alma,
que algo é ficcional não é
suficiente para evitar
que ele nos afete de outras maneiras.
Em particular, Platão está
preocupado com 3 formas que a ficção
pode afetar a alma.
E, mais importante, está
disposto a absolver uma 4ª.
E analisar os detalhes disso nos
permitirá ter uma melhor noção
da imagem de Platão.
Então o que preocupa Platão
quando ele alega sobre
a capacidade da ficção em afetar as
partes não-racionais da alma?
Ele está preocupado, antes de tudo,
com esse tipo de coisa que
preocupava Dan Quayle.
Esta observação de uma
circunstância particular
numa representação
ficcional e, então,
ponderar sobre isso como uma
forma disponível de vida
que pode levar a modelos errôneos.
Ele está ainda mais
profundamente preocupado com,
quando vemos algo num contexto ficcional
e a reconhecemos
explicitamente como
ficção,
isso que nos permite responder
de um jeito diferente
do que seria se fosse real,
nos afetando
emocionalmente e sendo
capaz
de mudar as nossas atitudes de
aprovação ou desaprovação.
O que ele não está preocupado
– e isso vai ser crucial para o
argumento maior que eu estou fazendo –
é com a imitação lúdica.
Casos em que nos envolvemos com o
material a uma certa distância,
não apenas no nível da racionalidade,
mas também em relação às partes
do nosso sistema de resposta
que não estão sujeitas à
regulação racional.
Platão reconhece que a
capacidade da imitação lúdica
está disponível para nós.
E é o contraste entre
esta e a 4ª coisa,
a que Platão encontra
mais problemática,
que vai nos ajudar a chegar ao
coração da imagem platônica.
Porque o mais problemático nela
– e eu vou dar algumas analogias
contemporâneas sobre isso –
são os casos em que a imitação
de figuras imaginárias
e a habituação a esse tipo de
comportamento levam ao
que Aristóteles nos adverte
tão profundamente:
um repertório equivocado de
respostas automáticas.
Portanto, para dar sentido a este
argumento tão sutil de Platão,
é preciso dar um passo
para trás e lembrar
onde ele se situa no
argumento de A República.
Vocês se lembram que, no
início do semestre,
em janeiro, começamos lendo as
páginas de abertura
do Livro II de A República de Platão
em que o personagem Glauco,
ao lado do seu irmão Adimanto,
desafia Sócrates a
responder à questão:
por que deveríamos ser justos?
E Glauco e Adimanto, juntos,
apresentam 3 tipos de argumentos,
3 tipos de afirmações a
favor da visão
de que a justiça não é algo que nos
envolvemos por razões intrínsecas,
mas algo que nos envolvemos por uma
questão de contingências
que passa a ser
instrumentalmente valiosa.
Glauco oferece um argumento
categorizando a justiça
no tipo de bem que valorizamos apenas
por causa dos seus
benefícios de reputação
e oferece algo como uma análise do
dilema do prisioneiro da justiça
sendo a 2ª melhor escolha de todos.
Ele, então, apresenta uma história de
ficção – a história do anel
de Giges, seguida pela
história das estátuas –
que se destina a convencer de
uma maneira diferente.
E, finalmente, Adimanto aponta
para uma continuidade
entre o que está representado no
contexto das histórias ficcionais
e que está representado no
contexto dos ditados comuns.
Onde é que começa o argumento
fornecido por Sócrates?
Será que Sócrates responde
diretamente a 1, 2 e 3?
Responde aos 3 argumentos precisos
apresentados por Glauco e Adimanto?
Não.
O que ele faz é oferecer um
quadro mais amplo
para pensar sobre essas questões,
a analogia entre a pessoa e a cidade.
Uma discussão do Livro II,
que nós não lemos,
sobre 2 tipos existentes de cidades.
E então, no contexto do Livro IV,
ele apresenta as 3 partes
da cidade e as 3 partes da alma.
Ele afirma que, assim como na
cidade ideal há guardiões,
soldados e trabalhadores, no
indivíduo há a razão,
o espírito e o apetite.
E vocês se lembram quando
tínhamos muita neve que
eu não encontrei melhor maneira de
representar a humanidade
que não fosse por um boneco de neve,
e analisamos os detalhes desse paralelo.
Nós analisamos como a
menor parte direcional
da alma é a razão.
A do meio é o espírito.
A inferior é o apetite.
E isso corresponde a esses auxiliares,
soldados e guardiões.
Agora, a fim de ver o que está
acontecendo na discussão
dos Livros III e IV que lemos para
hoje e na discussão do Livro X,
todos sobre a censura da poesia,
precisamos reconhecer algo
realmente muito interessante
sobre o que ocorre a seguir ao Livro II.
Lembrem-se: temos o desafio de Glauco,
por que deveríamos ser justos?
E a resposta bizarra de Sócrates,
que envolve a invocação da
analogia cidade-estado.
O que acontece em seguida é que
Sócrates passa a fornecer
um modelo de como os guardiões
?devem ser educados.
E o tipo de educação que ele está
preocupado é com a educação
de uma das partes não-racionais
da alma do guardião.
O que está acontecendo aqui é o
reconhecimento de Platão,
dada a imagem que ele tem do
Estado, de que a argumentação
não tem uma influência
poderosa em todos os homens,
"mas é preciso cultivar
primeiro a alma do estudioso
por meio de hábitos", como
diria Aristóteles.
O mesmo sugere Platão,
colocando a educação dos guardiões
imediatamente após a
discussão sobre a natureza
e valor da justiça,
assim como é crucial pensar
sobre a estrutura do estado
não apenas do ponto de
vista das leis...
isso regulado por meio da razão...
Mas também do ponto de vista das
influências não-racionais.
Portanto, Platão diz, voltando-se para
a educação dos guardiões,
que a 1ª pergunta a ser feita
quando pensamos sobre o
aspecto do estado ideal é:
como é a educação infantil,
o cultivo adequado do espírito e
do apetite nos guardiões?
E só quando isso estiver no lugar
estamos em posição de enfocarmos
o que é mais valorizado por
Platão na sua discussão:
o cultivo da razão.
Então, vamos ver exatamente o
que Platão tem a dizer
sobre a educação infantil.
E ao apresentar isso a vocês,
eu quero lembrá-los
de algo mencionado na última aula
sobre a Nozick e Rawls.
Vocês devem se lembrar que eu disse
que em todo o índice de Uma
Teoria da Justiça
e em todo o índice de
Anarquia, Estado e Utopia
há 2 referências às crianças.
Não há, basicamente, nenhuma
discussão sobre educação,
enquanto que esta é a 1ª coisa
que Platão menciona na sua
discussão sobre o estado ideal.
Ele questiona: como será a
educação dos guardiões?
"E não sabes que o começo,
em todas as coisas,
é sempre o mais importante, ...
mormente para os jovens?
É sobretudo nessa época
que os modelamos
e que eles recebem a marca que
pretendemos imprimir-lhes.
Vamos permitir, por negligência,
que as crianças ouçam as primeiras
fábulas que lhes apareçam,
criadas por indivíduos quaisquer,
e recebam em seus espíritos
entender, quando forem adultos?
E, sendo este um diálogo
socrático, o interlocutor diz:
"De forma alguma permitiremos".
E Sócrates continua:
"Portanto, parece-me que precisamos
começar por vigiar os
criadores de fábulas, ...
separar as suas
composições boas das
más.
Convenceremos as amas e as mães a
[...] modelarem-lhes a alma
com as suas fábulas muito mais do que
o corpo com as suas mãos".
Mais recentemente, esse
personagem familiar,
o Monstro das Bolachas,
em conformidade com as declarações
que Sócrates acabou de fazer,
começou a cantar canções como "A
Cookie is a Sometimes Thing"
e a aparecer em vídeos sobre
alimentos saudáveis.
É o reconhecimento de que as
primeiras narrativas
desempenham um papel
estranhamente formativo
nas atitudes dos jovens que poderia
levar a esse tipo de mudança.
Portanto, a 1ª preocupação de Platão
é essa que acabo de identificar.
A ideia de que
vocês serão apresentados a um
modelo a que aceitarão,
equivocadamente, como uma maneira
razoável de existência.
Segundo ele, quando os
poetas contam histórias
em que os heróis cometem atos
horríveis e ímpios,
estas histórias são prejudiciais
para as pessoas que as ouvem.
"Pois que homem não perdoará
sua própria iniquidade
se estiver convencido de que faz
apenas o que praticam
e praticaram os descendentes dos deuses.
Motivos estes que nos induzem a
rejeitar semelhantes histórias,
por receio de que
instiguem nossos jovens
a praticar com leviandade
as piores ações."
Se estiver ao seu alcance um personagem
(real ou imaginário)
que se comporta de um modo
específico, diz Platão,
você corre o risco de ver o seu
comportamento moldado por ele.
Ainda mais perigoso, porém,
é a possibilidade
– por causa da nossa relação
complicada com a ficção –
de responder a algo imaginário
de uma forma diferente
o suficiente para distorcer a
nossa experiência,
mas semelhante o suficiente para nos
afetar de forma implícita.
"Quando vemos – diz
Platão no Livro X –
Homero ou qualquer outro poeta
trágico imitar um herói na dor,
que, no meio dos seus lamentos,
se estende numa longa tirada ou
canta ou bate no peito,
sentimos, como sabes, prazer.
Acompanhamos tudo isso com a
nossa simpatia e, louvamos
como um bom poeta aquele que [...]
provocou em nós tais disposições."
E o fazemos mesmo
quando isso contraria a nossa reflexão
sobre como devemos nos comportar.
Ele segue: "Quando uma
desgraça doméstica nos fere,
já percebeste que fazemos força por
manter a atitude contrária,
ficarmos calmos e mostrar coragem,
porque isso é próprio de um homem
e o comportamento que há
instantes aplaudíamos
só fica bem às mulheres?"
E ele avança passando por outra
série de emoções sobre isso.
Ele diz que assim como podemos
fazer isso para a tristeza,
gostamos do humor caricato no
contexto da ficção.
Gostamos de certos tipos de
comportamentos impróprios
no contexto da ficção.
Mas nós estamos, segundo ele,
numa distância errada da segurança.
Nesse sentido, a nossa relação
com a ficção é paradoxal.
Por um lado, há diferença
suficiente entre ficção e realidade
que deixamos as nossas
emoções correrem soltas.
A razão diz: é apenas imaginação.
Não importa como eu responda a isto.
Não é a realidade.
Não é o reflexo de quem eu sou.
Mas na medida em que existe uma
semelhança suficiente
entre os 2 casos, na medida em que
o distanciamento acontece
apenas no nível da razão,
existe um risco de contágio.
E talvez seja possível ver isso
contrastando os tipos de casos que
Platão se preocupa com os tipos de
casos em que ele não é ostensivo.
No Livro III, Platão admite que há
certos contextos em que parece
estar bem se envolver com a
imaginação, se envolver com a
ficção.
Ele escreve – falando agora
dos guardiões –:
ao se deparar com um personagem
indigno dele mesmo, ele não
está disposto a se parecer de
verdade com o personagem inferior.
Em vez disso, ele sente "vergonha
de fazer uma coisa dessas,
a menos que esteja em jogo".
E parece – trata-se de um fato
extremamente interessante
sobre os seres humanos – que somos
capazes, em alguns contextos,
de assumir uma postura
genuinamente de jogo.
Na minha seção, quando eu jogava
o Dilema do Prisioneiro,
uma pobre caloura que jogou contra mim
– ela está sentada aqui
na 3ª fila –
não entendeu que eu estava
jogando pelo jogo,
o que significava que eu
estava jogando de verdade,
e eu a derrotei em cada rodada.
E ela perdeu muito dinheiro
e eu ganhei muito.
Agora, ao fazer isso, o meu
sentimento é que eu tinha saído
de um domínio em que o
contágio era um risco.
Não apenas no nível de pensar
sobre o meu envolvimento,
mas o próprio envolvimento em si
tinha uma espécie de
distância irônica.
Algumas representações
ficcionais nos levam a absorver
pelo menos uma parte do seu conteúdo.
Em Monty Python, quando vocês
assistirem Sir Lancelot
cortar os braços e depois as
pernas do Cavaleiro Negro,
que está saltando enquanto sangra,
não é o caso – imagino –
de que haja um pequeno risco de
contágio a casos reais
de membros perdidos.
Mas sim que um certo tipo de atitude
lúdica está se desenrolando.
Pelo menos até que ela
seja interrompida.
Eu fui, por um ótimo motivo,
questionada por um dos
alunos desta classe
sobre uma apresentação lúdica em aula
no contexto da nossa
discussão sobre punição,
num exemplo em que alguém
pretendia atirar em alguém
e tinha ou não sucesso no seu
objetivo... tudo isso um dia depois
de ter havido um tiroteio em New Haven.
Às vezes, a realidade que
envolve uma situação
faz com que seja quase
impossível para nós,
por causa da maneira que ela permeia as
nossas respostas não-racionais,
assumir uma postura lúdica.
Mas o fato de sermos capazes de
entrar e sair desta atitude é,
penso eu, um dos fatos mais
interessantes e intrigantes
sobre os seres humanos.
O que é inegável é que,
além de sermos capazes de
nos envolvermos
neste tipo de imitação distante,
lúdica, cópia não habitual...
também somos capazes de nos
envolvermos numa imitação
que dá origem ao hábito.
Platão escreve: "[Os guardiões]
que imitem as virtudes
que lhes convém adquirir
desde a infância".
Ou seja, "a coragem, a
sensatez e a pureza".
Eles "não devem imitar a baixeza
nem ser capazes de imitá-la,
[...] pelo perigo de que, a
partir da imitação,
usufruam o prazer da realidade.
Tu não percebeste que quando se cultiva
a imitação desde a infância,
ela se transforma em hábito e
natureza para o corpo,
a voz e a mente?".
Louco? Bem, aqui está um artigo
do The New York Times da semana passada
discutindo o videogame Madden NFL'12.
Alguém aqui joga este jogo online?
Excelente.
Portanto, qual é a
característica do Madden
NFL'12
que chocou o NY Times?
Era esta.
Na nova versão do Madden NFL'12,
um jogador que sofre uma concussão
é automaticamente eliminado do jogo.
"Desde que a gravidade das lesões
cerebrais se tornaram evidentes
em escala nacional", diz o
artigo de 2 de abril,
"a mensagem principal para os
jovens jogadores de futebol
– se você receber uma
concussão ausente-
se do campo pelo resto do dia –
tem sido um dos mais difíceis para os
jovens aceitarem e executarem.
Essa realidade em breve será
auxiliada pela fantasia"...
é como se estivesse ecoando Platão...
"Madden NFL'12, a versão
de videogame da NFL
mais assustadoramente real, jogado
por milhões de pessoas,
vai ser realista o suficiente
não só ao mostrar
os jogadores sofrendo concussões,
mas também ao mostrar que
qualquer jogador que a sustente
será impedido de participar do
restante do jogo, sem exceções".
A fantasia no auxílio da
regulação social.
Aqui está outro exemplo:
Como é que os militares dos
EUA treinam os soldados
para o campo de batalha?
Algumas das coisas, claro, é
cultivar os seus corpos,
de tal forma que eles tenham a
força e resistência
para participar de determinadas ações.
Mas um dos principais
modos de treinamento
é pelos videogames.
Aqui estão uns soldados jogando o
que inicialmente foi usado
apenas como parte de um vídeo de
recrutamento para o exército,
uma ferramenta de recrutamento
chamado America's Army.
E, depois, desenvolvido
numa ferramenta de treinamento
para os próprios soldados.
Aqui está um grupo de soldados
jogando videogame.
E aqui está um artigo do Washington
Post de alguns anos atrás.
"Jogo de realidade virtual prepara
soldados para a guerra real.
Uma tarde escaldante no Iraque,
enquanto lutava contra os insurgentes
na cidade de Mosul, o
sargento Sinkway Sualez
abriu fogo com o seu calibre 50.
Essa foi apenas a segunda vez, diz
ele, que disparou num inimigo,
um inimigo humano.
– Parecia que eu estava num grande
jogo de videogame, disse.
– Ele nem sequer me
intimidou, atirando de volta.
Foi um instinto natural.
'Boom, boom, boom', lembra Sualez, uma
voz profunda de fala rápida,
29 anos de idade, de
Chesterfield, Virgínia.
Ele era engenheiro de combate no
Iraque há quase 1 ano.
E Sualez continua:
– Os insurgentes estavam
disparando do outro lado da ponte.
Chamamos um helicóptero
para um ataque aéreo.
Eu não podia acreditar no
que eu estava vendo.
Era como Halo. Não parecia
real. Mas era real ."
E no final do artigo, o repórter
cita um oficial do exército
do escritório de Modelagem e
Simulação de Defesa que diz:
"A tecnologia nos jogos
facilitou uma revolução
na arte da guerra.
Quando chegou o momento para ele" –
para Sualez, diz este oficial –
"disparar a sua arma ele estava
pronto para fazer isso
e foi capaz de fazer.
A sua experiência de liderança,
até então através da
formação em terra
e do jogo Halo,
permitiu-lhe a execução.
O seu conhecimento da
situação foi acionado.
Ele sabia o que tinha de fazer.
Ele tinha feito isso antes ou algo
parecido até esse ponto".
Assim, o argumento de Platão começa
a ganhar um pouco de força.
Mas como é o argumento exatamente?
O argumento de Platão que estivemos
considerando é o seguinte:
Platão sugere que a ficção afeta as
partes não-racionais da alma
de tal forma que elas estão
potencialmente dissonantes
da parte racional.
Ou seja, a ficção pode nos levar a
achar atraentes coisas que,
na reflexão, achamos
desagradáveis, ou achar
desagradáveis
??as coisas que, na
reflexão, achamos atraentes.
Ela também pode, claro,
permitir o cultivo de coisas
em harmonia com o nosso compromisso.
A terapia pode usar exatamente
as mesmas técnicas
do treinamento militar
virtual para alinhar
as nossas respostas não-racionais com
as nossas partes racionais.
Mas certamente é um risco
a ficção afetar
as partes não-racionais da alma
de uma forma que as torne
dissonantes da parte racional.
Platão diz que nós,
reflexivamente, desejamos ter
– por todas as razões que discutimos
na 1ª parte deste curso –
as nossas almas, pelo menos a
maior parte, em harmonia.
Quando não reagimos instintivamente
como estamos comprometidos a
agir reflexivamente
isso é difícil e
indesejável para nós.
Mas o que poderíamos pensar como o
modo mais fácil de sair
deste problema, dizendo para nós
mesmos "é só o Halo,
é apenas um jogo", acaba
não sendo suficiente.
Os indivíduos, afirma Platão, até
mesmo o melhor entre nós,
não podem regular esses efeitos
internamente pela própria razão.
Não estamos totalmente no
controle das nossas partes
pela razão.
Em vez disso, ele diz, é possível
regular esses efeitos externamente
ao permitir que a sociedade
tome decisões para nós
sobre o que é e o que não
é para ser exposto.
Consequentemente,
num argumento muito parecido com
o que vemos em Hobbes,
Platão está sugerindo no Livro X que
o que a racionalidade exige,
devido ao nosso reconhecimento dos
seus limites, é uma vontade
de restringir a nossa liberdade
de determinadas maneiras.
Assim como Hobbes argumenta que o
problema de coordenação
originado pelo Dilema do Prisioneiro
significa que temos de nos
sujeitar a um soberano
que toma o controle e faz
cumprir os contratos,
Platão também sugere que
precisamos nos submeter
a uma regulação pela reflexão
dos aspectos da experiência
que nos afetam de tal modo
que à distância sabemos o seu perigo,
mas que de perto somos
incapazes de nos proteger.
Agora, isso não é um
argumento fácil de aceitar.
Ele levanta todos os tipos
de questionamentos
sobre quem toma as decisões.
Ela levanta todos os tipos de
questionamentos sobre se a manipulação
não-racional é, de fato,
o papel do Estado.
Mas também nos lembra que,
se nós estamos tentando pensar sobre o
que as estruturas políticas
precisam ser para as criaturas
complicadas, como nós mesmos,
não haverá, no final,
nenhuma resposta fácil.
E, na próxima aula,
eu vou começar com o que
será a 1ª pergunta:
O que isso tem a ver com Sunstein?
Nesse meio tempo, eu vou publicar os
slides relacionados a Sunstein;
se vocês quiserem ter uma vantagem
inicial na 2ª pergunta,
sobre como a persuasão não-racional
deve ocorrer na sociedade,
podem dar uma olhada neles
durante o fim de semana.
Muito obrigada
e eu vejo vocês na terça-feira.